remember I said and I started purses
informally right just so you could see
the logic in my head I said look I want
all the Z squared tones because only
those terms will give me the pairs of
cosines then I'm after in this actual
result okay that's what's gonna do it
for me okay
now this this is only two of them there
are a bunch more and it's not hard to
just go through logically and find them
I've already got a couple let me I'd do
it properly okay so what I've got here
is I'm gonna write down all the terms
write down all the Zen squared terms
that's that's the logic that I'm
applying here okay now on the left hand
side writing down the Z square terms it
is really easy you write down zero okay
there are all the Zed squared terms on
the left but then I take the very same
object on the right and it does have
Sanskrit terms so let's write them all
down this time I'm going to be a little
bit illogical about it rather than just
picking them out random I'm gonna try
and do it left to right in some order so
that I don't miss any because that's
gonna be kind of important right so in
fact even though I picked out these
because they're the ones I want the
first ed squared term has no cosines in
it at all do you see it this is it's
quit right there if you multiply it by
this one this one you'll get dead
squared so there you go there's as it's
quit
there's my first one okay then I say
okay well where can I get my next one
well I can't use this sin squared term
anymore I've already got the single time
that it will give me a dead squinter
because if I multiply by anything else
for instance if I multiply this one by
this one I'm dead to the fork I'm out
okay if I multiply this by saying this
I'll get said cubed and again I'm out
okay so this guy is not useful to me
anymore okay does that make sense but
then I move up to the next one and this
one I'll do the red hair that's in fact
the first one that I see so I've got
plus four that's where the cause the
first angle cause the second hey go
there's a second said squared term I see
yes
Oh like we can do the red one
yeah I'm not finished yet I'll go finish
okay so you remember how I said the Zed
squared term there it's finished I can
really use it the ones but this guy here
the red one I can use them again I don't
have to parent with him I can pair with
this guy that'll give me the Zen square
time all right so what I'm going to get
is watch out there is um still a plus 4z
squared at the front but this time is
the first angle and the last and you
okay with that okay now again I'm just
trying to make sure I don't miss
anything is there anything else I can
pair up this guy with I'm done a pen on
with him hang out with him I'm finished
he's useless to me now okay all right
now I have a look at this guy can I use
him yes I can write I can pair them with
him and him that'll give me as N squared
right that's good can I still use that
one turn at the front I can i pair them
up with this sin squared and this one
right but I can pair up with this one
out of this sin square and I'll still
get as N squared term right so I get
another one okay all right can I use
this term anymore yes nope he's done oh
yes you're right no I I have I have I've
used up my said squares over there okay
but I haven't used up these two guys
okay so I get what am I getting for Z
cos o swear 4.98 pile of mine that's the
second in 13 okay there's always a
double negative happening okay so now
I've exhausted that one okay can I use
this guy I've used him can I use this
guy I have used him twice here and here
he's done can I use him I've actually
used all of them I've done the more you
can just go off and you can check okay
so now I have the left-hand side I wrote
a right-hand side I guess a by
comparison of coefficients
okay no more head spread times I just
want the coefficients of the zips pants
so I've got zero here how many said
Squared's do I have by themselves
the answer is three them one two three
three and then I've got these other guys
here let's see here so I've got four cuz
soup I own nine calls for pi 9 Thank You
CI but for them I've also got form this
one eight nine and I've got four of this
one you care with that now I'm almost
there I only have to do a couple of
things now okay ah no no I have no more
Zen's all the bellezza said square turns
I haven't divided I haven't done either
way I'm comparing the coefficients
that's what I'm doing it okay
I can't actually divide through but
that's not really what I'm doing this is
what I'm really doing um so then how do
I get here from here okay well firstly I
don't want that three over there I'm
gonna write it as an equals negative
three okay and then the rest of it
there's a common factor of four all of
them and then I've got all these guys
except I know what the a pile entire do
i I am getting pile nine young which
cars wants the negative and the pilot
pound idea which cars for submitting do
you see it so now I can write here is
the first pair of maples take away the
second take away the last one and now to
get the result that I left off I just
divide by fail and that gives me
negative 3/4 now just to say because you
can write in a pitch running out of time
if this question said hence all
otherwise you could get out your handy
little friend here and be very very
patient and careful with your brackets
and put that thing in and it will
dutifully tell you you minus 0.75
because it is okay however on this
question if that was the exact wording
you did that you'd get a big fat zero
because you haven't used any of their
results so the answer is minus three